after having to suffer one of the
world's longest and most restrictive
lockdowns filipinos are out and about
daily kobit 19 cases are down to
hundreds from a peak of 20 000 a day
during the delta wave of infections
most restrictions have now been lifted
but the country's main airport remains
only half as busy as it was before the
pandemic the threat of the omicron
variant has halted the government's plan
to reopen borders
the first way by which the first
strategy we've employed to delay the
entry of the omicron variant is to ban
the entry of the travelers from
countries that have community
transmission of the virus variant
migrant filipino workers are exempted
from the ban but that doesn't mean they
can travel without difficulty there are
around 10 million filipinos working
overseas each year many of them look
forward to coming home during the
holiday season
but the emergence of the immigrant
variant has disrupted international
travel john gonzaga who works as a nurse
in the uk has not been back in the
philippines for two years he had hoped
to be able to fly home this christmas
but the uk's american surge has made
that impossible because of the new
variant of omicron
and the number of cases that have been
increasing
they're now putting back actually the
the old protocols that we have in the
first wave i think um
pretty soon
they will be able they will announce
that um we're going to be on lockdown
because all the neighboring countries
are on lockdown already and it's not
just leaving that's difficult
john says he has friends who are having
a hard time getting back to the uk
they're in manila at the moment but um i
was they just told me that they wouldn't
be able to to come back here
um because of the travel restrictions
despite travel constraints however the
philippines health department has
detected the omegran variant in three
international travelers
there's a fear it will quickly spread
but the government says the situation is
under control barnabilo al jazeera
manila